five months after two men shot and
killed a father as he was leaving his
job metro police and his family continue
to search for answers our 8 news now
i-team has been looking into this murder
for weeks now david charns here with how
you can help out david yeah bryan denise
alfonso turner would be turning 30 years
old next month but two men shot and
killed him in may now his family and
police hope you may have information to
crack the case
my brother was the love of our lives
jerica arrington says her younger
brother alfonso turner or al as she
called him was funny kind the light of
their big family he was very humorous
and goofy
very positive at 29 turner a father of
four worked a steady job as a security
guard here at an apartment complex on
mountain vista near sahara and nellis
he'd go i got kids i ain't got time for
that
so we just coined that phrase i didn't
realize how much i quote him until
i lost him on the night of may 8th
turner was in a car leaving work when
two men started firing in all the men
shot 40 times anytime you have that type
of gun
that many gunshots
is concerning homicide lieutenant ray
spencer says another man was in the
passenger seat he wasn't hurt and at
this point they don't know who the
target was but they're sure this isn't a
robbery gone wrong at this point we
don't have
any viable leads that we're following up
on he had a lot of friends he didn't
have enemies
i know that
someone tried to attack a friend and he
hit him
about a week before arrington says
investigators have found no connection
with anyone her brother knew and the
crime with what would be turner's 30th
birthday now approaching she's hoping
for answers i want people to come
forward because it's the right thing to
do
you saw turner there at a grave site his
father a former nfl running back was
shot and killed by police during an
incident 10 years ago as with all of our
vegas unsolved cases crime stoppers
shrime stoppers that is is offering a
reward for any information leading to a
conviction in this case and all the
others you can always leave anonymous
tips by calling them or going right to
their website of course we've posted all
that information on our website and
inside our app tonight as well i'm david
charns live local now denise